in the case of abortion according to the
Liberals there is a conflict between two
rights the baby's right not to be
murdered and the mother's right to
control her own body in the familiar
language of the Declaration of
Independence the the conflict that the
Liberals view here is between the baby's
right to life and the mother's right to
Liberty or to the pursuit of happiness
but even according to this liberal
framing abortion is not defensible
because the right to life is not merely
one right among many
the right to life is the fundamental
right without which none of the other
rights are possible Thomas Jefferson did
not list life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness at random without life there
can be no Liberty without Liberty one
cannot pursue happiness even according
to the liberal framework it would be
incoherent to claim that one's right to
Liberty trumped another's right to life
since the right to Liberty depends upon
the right to life